now we're just sort about enjoying the
moment is obviously being young and
everything I think for everyone it's
this is a very rare moment you don't get
many moments like this in your career so
I think all we've got to do now is enjoy
it soak every bit of it up and then when
that when the season comes around is
when we start preparing there was enough
people at Wembley to fill this whole
stadium three times over so it's really
nice for the people who weren't able to
get tickets to be able to show their
sports today and for us to be able to
give them thanks back in a way as well
the voice is gone as you can as you can
see and in here
um but yeah I mean 48 Hours has been a
whirlwind
still quite hasn't sunk in yet
um
and I mean yeah we're just here to
celebrate this wonderful day with the
with the town you know what we can do in
um we're gonna try to prove it next
season obviously we've got hard work to
do over the summer and um hopefully
um we do well and uh we'll see what
happens yeah I still don't think he's
sunk in yet
um but no it's been it's just been a
great season Charmaine for everyone
involved
it's just honestly it's hard to put it
it's hard to describe the way it feels
like but nice it's unreal honestly